it's about to be epic
it's about to be crazy
this is about to be epically crazy
in chronological order this is the
second Transformers movie it takes place
during the 90s shortly after Bumblebee
if you find a kid struggling with how
he's able to provide for his family my
character noise ex-military and I feel
like I'm failing at every turn
then I meet Mirage
[Music]
[Applause]
Pete Davidson is the what's up Mirage
he's found like the rebellious Autobot
you looking good man
there you go now we're friends
Elena works at the Museum she's
investigating something which brings
Noah into her life who are you uh
janitor really and that kind of opens a
whole new world for us
in this crazy Journey with the Autobots
we meet the maximals
we meet the next level of villains how
big can this guy be
uh he eats planets so like way bigger
than a planet
action
there's humor
and there's a lot of heart they're going
against their biggest Nemesis ever
[Music]
they've never based anything like this
before let them come